German tanks there are no strangers to
the battlefield and overwatch has won
itself Reinhardt yes precision German
engineering tell me about this guy he's
good at sitting on payloads I know that
for my goodness Reinhardt is your
objective dude all right like you are on
the payload when it's moving you are
pushing in to capture points you are
using that big shield to be the front
man for your team you are the front line
as Reinhardt and so that makes him a
super valuable player and also because
of his skill set he's a pretty easy
character to step in and play so what
else does he do apart from the shield
right we all see the shield it's great
for sitting on points but what does he
do in terms of attacking you're you're
having the shield up but people are
gonna want to get around your shield
they're gonna want to get close to you
to take you down so when they get close
don't be afraid to just drop that shield
and take some swings your hammer covers
a big area take a few swings inside the
spawn area see what junk you knock over
that's a good way to get a sense for
just the kind of area you can cover with
those hammer swings excellent what about
the charge obviously they have the
charge then people slam them up against
walls when should you be using this and
winches you know the charge is tricky
because you don't want to charge way
past your team get caught behind enemy
lines and cuz they will just cheer you
up you also don't want to go flying off
into oblivion there are a lot of edges
on these maps and don't worry it's a
Reinhardt rite of passage we've all done
that but the charge is great for
singling out offense heroes who are
trying to get your goat because you will
pin them and you will kill them in one
shot
also if tanks like road hog and Winston
are meddling all up in your face you pin
them not only do they get a bit of a
stun and get a chunk of their health out
but you'll be able to swing on them and
bring them down and also the charge is
really an eye-catching move so your
teammates sees you running off with
Winston they're gonna pile on the damage
they're gonna take down whoever you've
been what about his fire strike it seems
like it almost gets lost in the move set
when should you be using that they gave
him a projectile so you can throw out
this projectile and it does do
significant damage it covers a pretty
good area so and it also goes through
shields
you can harass an enemy Reinhardt that
way you can get through Winston shields
you can really cause some happen you can
cause some disruption and so I say use
that as frequently as you can it's worth
dropping the shield for a hot second to
throw it out even if a turret is sort of
focusing down on you because you can
chip away at that turret you can get
your shield right back up and then
you're back in the protecting business
he's got a pretty meaty alt and earth
shatter it's able to knock down a bunch
of people when should you be using that
can you do it on your own or should you
have some backup throwing the hammer
down Rock knock people down in a cone in
front Ewan deals damage and then you can
wade in and sort of get a few hammer
swings in before they kick back up but
if you get a few people down or if you
get a tank down you're probably not
going to be able to take them out
yourself teaming up with other players
to do damage to help shoot the
characters who are on the ground maybe
throw their alt in there affero alt
adjunct rat alt those can be great
damage multipliers and a great way to
take down a significant chunk of the
team fast so who are some of the
matchups that are gonna work at best for
you who does your shield sort of work
against and who are you most exposed
with with Reinhardt well the shield is a
great way to make soldier 76 make
Widowmaker make these characters that
are trying to do mid-range to long range
damage to take them out of the game
almost you know make them reposition
because you can soak up a lot and you're
gonna get a lot of payload movement out
of them of course the shield does need
to recharge and you will have characters
who just hammer on your shield just to
make it go down whenever you're not
using it it's recharging but you're also
exposed so use some of the alcoves to
duck into people aren't necessarily
going to pursue you in there because you
have a huge hammer so you can usually
take a second just try to communicate to
your teammates when the shield is going
down and if you're playing with the
Reinhardt keep an eye on the shield
yourself cracks start to show when it's
gonna go down so you know you can't put
all the blame on Reinhardt when all of a
sudden that Bastion turret is hammering
you down I always feel like when I'm
playing is Ryan out that when I hear
we're junk rats a fire in the hole I get
to head out of Dodge is there any other
sort of characters you should be wary of
you know who gets my goat all the time
is may yeah thumbs up and she can freeze
you and then she can headshot you with
her ice bolt and then you're dead and
it's like the biggest size discrepancy
in the entire game but I mean David
beats Goliath every almost every time so
you want to close with may very quickly
hit her with a fire strike maybe get a
hammer swinging
or just back up and get your team to
help you out just remember you can point
the shield in any direction you can
adapt for when again to your tracer gets
behind you if a fare is above you you
can block some of that but you're also
exposing the parts that you're not
blocking for sure like every a German
tank the weak point is at the box you
got to be careful when you're playing as
Reinhardt thanks so much for the tips
Christ and for more tips on overwatch
stay tuned to games.com and hit that
subscribe